today uber and lyft drivers nationwide
went on strike in several major cities
including Los Angeles where we taped
this show this is incredible can you
believe it had yeah I mean I take an
uber to work every day and today I had
to be my owner bird driver but I
understand you had to be your own uber
driver yes my own ruber driver and it
was awful take a look so your name's
Andy huh yeah my name is Andy - so is
that your house back there it's nice
yeah it smiles a lot of windows though
you know you gotta be careful peepers a
lot of creeps out there mm-hmm hey you
probably get asked this a lot are you
that guy from Conan no you sure you you
really look like him look I would know
if I was the guy from Conan okay I got I
got waters if you want one no thanks
here you want an Altoid no I'm good
they're they're fresh so it's like a
fresh pack you want sorry hey do you
like music
mm-hmm not really cuz um I have a band
and we're playing the show at Petco on
Tuesday night
I got a flier here if you want it yeah
sure thanks great you want a water you
already asked me that do you listen to
podcasts because I have one and it's I
just started and it's really good that's
part of it it's s3 it's just me and my
opinions about those property brothers
excuse me so I'm you single want to get
a drink or something or a coffee or a
computer or something no I'm good
okay cuz I mean like now I know where
you live so I could just I could swing
by and pick you up I'm actually moving
soon oh okay okay
well have a good day
two stars blabbermouth
two stars talks too much and no tip dick
you've had it with yourself